he loved my children it wasn't something
he feared he seemed to be comfortable
with the enormity of the ex-husband I
mean you know I felt like I was not
coming with baggage I had trunks I think
by now you've probably heard that Demi
Moore is a very candid in her new memoir
inside out
I mean she's talking about her childhood
abuse drugs drinking and her marriages
to both Bruce Willis and Ashton Kutcher
and let me just say things get real
personal Jimmy opens up about Ashton's
cheating you got a Google Alert yes what
did you say to him I asked if it was
true and he admitted it right away and I
think my response was are you kidding me
yeah Jimmy also reveals that at 42 she
became pregnant with Ashton's child but
suffered a miscarriage
and you tried again quite a few times I
can't even really bring fully to words
how lost empty desperate confused I
really lost sight of everything that was
right in front of me which is the family
I had
she says the miscarriage caused her to
turn to drugs and drinking after 20
years of sobriety
then enter vicodin twelve pills a day
yeah it definitely got up there okay
first of all I just want to say that I
commend to me for her openness and this
memoir it cannot be easy but Ashton
might not be feeling the same way on
Tuesday the day of the books release he
tweeted quote I was about to push the
button on a really snarky tweet then I
saw my son daughter and wife and I
deleted it he also tweeted this quote
life is good crediting his dad Larry and
then this one for truth tech
me which is just a way to sign up for
his community aptX
but still the timing on all three of
these is a little suspect as for where
things stand for Jimmy and Ashton
now well in the memoir she writes quote
I'm grateful to Ashton - believe it or
not whatever pain we went through
together enabled both of us to grow into
the people we are today we continue to
collaborate with our foundation thorn
and I'm so proud of the work we do and
in a new interview with The Wall Street
Journal she says quote we have some
things that overlap its friendly but
we're not hanging out in that same
interview Jimmy says she's not currently
dating quote right now I'm focusing on
my relationship with myself et was just
with Demi where she opened up about how
her three daughters rumor Scout and
Tallulah feel about the memoir you know
it's it's everything it really is I feel
so much gratitude and and just joy it's
just that's it okay so a lot to unpack
here Jimmy's new memoir is available now
of course for all the latest on Demi
Ashton and more of your favorite celebs
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]